okay kick it off
okay yeah we're finally getting around
to doing another
david cronenberg movie yeah cronenberg
man he delivers i
you know [ __ ] that he's a canadian
gem
he really is he's a canadian national
treasurer
yeah some weird [ __ ] you know what i
mean although i must say
he's one of a kind i have to say this
movie although it's a very good movie
it's one of his better movies in terms
of just the way it's filmed
the way it looks and the tone it's not
as
weird as like say like the brood or
video drone and [ __ ] like that
i like those little but those are the
ones i grew up with yeah yeah this one's
a little more polished
and it's i think it's because the
subject matter
it trips women out a little bit more
than it trips guys out i think
the thing about this one uh we're
talking about dead ringers in case my
shirt didn't give it away
yeah um but this is
actually i don't know for a while i
probably would have said that this was
my favorite david cronenberg movie i'm
not sure because that
moves around because you know he has so
many good ones like video drum the fly
the brood like all this other stuff so i
feel like we've done a lot of cronenberg
we did video jerome we did
uh rabid yeah we did we do the brood
probably i think we did the brood we
might have done shivers as well yeah
uh so we're kind of working our way
through that we haven't done like some
of his
like you know we haven't done existence
or spider or any of his like
newer stuff eastern promises i think in
terms of like groundbreaking [ __ ]
i think video jerome's his best movie
yeah i think he's probably his weirdest
i think the one that affected me the
most though was the brood
and maybe because i was younger when i
saw it yeah because it was an older
movie than and i was pretty young when
it came out and that just was a [ __ ]
weird movie
yeah the brood especially the baby
licking at the end
all that [ __ ] just the whole concept
well his
david cronenberg's whole thing and dead
ringers was also kind of a prime example
of it
was kind of the what entails
from the separation of the mind from the
body
you know what i mean or like people who
are trying to intellectualize themselves
like
out of the body or like the weird
relationship between
because i mean look at the brood where
it's like the woman the babies are
basically
manifestations of her like physical
manifestations of her
emotional psychological rage yeah um you
know so he's and it's weird she's like
giving birth to him like a queen aunt
yeah yeah yeah just like he has more and
more babies and they [ __ ] serve her
it's like a
hive mind and i just just the style of
that movie
the time in which it came out the
architecture it involved
early 80s you know what i mean and the
age at which i saw it
you know i mean that movie affected me i
think more so than
than video drum yeah i could see that
it was just odd yeah i mean i think a
lot of
david cronenberg i feel like he gets a
lot of the same
criticisms leveled at him that say
stanley kubrick
gets leveled at him in the sense that he
almost seems to
hold people at arm's length or like you
know he has a very clinical or a very
detached
kind of way of looking at the world but
i don't
know i don't know if i ever found like i
see what people are
saying but i don't think i ever found
that particularly i don't find his
movies
they're weird but they don't i don't
find them particularly off-putting in
the sense that
um you know the concept is off-putting
or i feel
that they're cold or uncaring um and
particularly dead ringers where i feel
like it does have a really like
uh you know kind of a heartbreaking
emotional core to it
while still being kind of detached and
but i feel like kubrick
had the same kind of thing it's like a
hard thing to pull off but
so i can see what people are saying when
they make that criticism but this this
particular one visually i think is one
of his best movies
uh the set you know they're not really
sets but the location yeah and he's
his uh art director i think has been the
same woman for like a really long time
so she did like a whole bunch of his
like very iconic movies
you could tell the budget is bit is
pretty good on this one this almost
seems like almost like a mainstream
movie yeah
well because this was the one that came
between the fly had come out two years
previous to this because dead ringers
came out in 1988
and then after this in 1990 or 1991 was
naked lunch yeah um you know which was
uh
that was a novel adaptation yeah i
haven't seen that in a long time but
yeah
i got to get the flying naked launch i'm
missing those two yeah i mean i just
watched the fly recently and i still
love that [ __ ] movie i mean that is a
fantastic movie
dead ringers it's like it usually gets
classed in with horror which i guess it
is because it does have
some touches of you know a little bit of
the gore a little bit of the
body horror that cronenberg is kind of
known for but i feel like dead ringers
is more
uh an internal movie in the way that
he's more worried about the psychology
of these twins and this weird like
psychosexual like kind of exploring this
weird psychosexual
relationship that they have yeah which
kind of physics
you know manifests itself physically a
little bit but it usually is like
kind of kept inside and they're
gynecologists and they're [ __ ] weird
yeah they're kind of abusive certain
these two characters kind of remind me
of bateman out of [ __ ] american
psycho slightly
yeah at least elliot does yeah yeah one
of the twins yeah
and and another weird thing about this
movie is that it's kind of inspired by a
real a real set of twins we did a show
on our dirt we did we did a show about
uh stewart and cyril marcus twin
gynecologist in new york city who they
found
uh they were dead in their apartment
they were hoarders right or was that
someone else
they were dead in an apartment filled
with [ __ ] garbage and they were
[ __ ] on the couch and it was just
man yeah you know your life's taking a
turn when you're [ __ ] on the couch
it's just stereotype yeah they're
[ __ ] they lost their minds
yeah some kind of joint psychosis
and these two dudes are [ __ ] they
call that foley i do
yeah two dudes madness madness between
two or madness shared with two
yeah not just dudes there's two people
like driving each other crazy
yeah or like one like madness rubbing
off on the other one they're like
usually it's it's usually romantic
partners or
siblings yeah um you know we did a
couple shows about that too about like
uh
crazy twins like that kind of thing so
that doesn't ever go crazy on me
i'm i'm too i'm just crazy on me man i'm
too sane to go crazy and
honestly i think you're probably more in
danger of that than i am
it's all my mental problems that's what
i mean i'm i'm too like i'm too grounded
i don't think i could ever i mean unless
i vent mine unless something like uh
unless something
physical like fries in there i just have
that jack torrance [ __ ] inner voice
and that thing from venom
that goes i i want to see their heads
roll like little toes
every time seriously every time we watch
the shining which is a lot you guys
but every time that scene with like jack
torrance coming down the hall toward the
girl where he's going
and i'm like hey it's you yes because
that just it reminds me of you like
everything
yeah it's kind of like a mixture of
venom and gollum
yeah in my head i can see that yeah i
can see that yeah
uh but yeah so yeah so uh deadbringers
is very loosely based on the case of
stuart and cyril
marcus and more there was a book about
them written that was called twins
and he kind of got the story idea from
that because he wrote it as or at least
co-wrote it as well
now i will okay so the whole story of
this is that
there's two twins beverly and elliot
mantle they were born in the 1950s and
at the beginning of the movie they just
show a very brief
um kind of prologue of them as kids
and it's notable that pretty much the
first conversation that these two have
with each other
is all about why humans have sex
and it's because humans don't live in
the water anymore
they're like if we were still fish and
lived in the water they would just like
leave the eggs and somebody would swim
over and fertilize them and everything
would
be easy but but because humans don't
live in the water they had to
internalize the water meaning that
you know now we have now yeah we have
the ocean
inside of here so there is a really
interesting
recurring theme in this movie which is
only i think
evident to me now that i've seen it so
many times and i've seen this movie
at least 50 times i mean i used to have
it on vhs back in the day because i
taped
it off cable and it was one that i just
like revisited over and over again
there's something about it
that is really compelling to me i mean i
love jeremy irons
um and i just love his performance in
this
the other thing about this movie that i
had kind of forgotten until i was
watching it again last night is that
it's
like really funny like not in a like oh
haha zany comedy kind of way but in like
a really like black humor kind of way
i mean i was like laughing out loud at
some other [ __ ] that that's what i was
saying it was kind of like american
psycho because there was humor in that
too in a way
yeah it's a similar kind of like it's a
very dark humor
like a very dry british kind of humor
which i like
so so there's a theme in this of these
two twins who
i feel like because they're so obsessed
with
the insides of people's bodies and
particularly the insides of women's
bodies because they come
become gynecologists they go they get to
the top of their field
um and they open their infertility
clinic where they're helping women get
pregnant
so i feel like the whole theme of this
is
that these two individuals are actually
just
one individual who cannot live without
one another
and their whole entire life is like
trying to
they're spending it trying to get back
into the womb
so that they can be one person
again you know what i'm saying i mean
that really seems to be a recurring
theme
of this movie because the two you know
and
okay so both parts are played by
uh jeremy irons now this movie came out
in 1988
and obviously you know they've been
doing like split screen
type of stuff like people playing twins
in movies prior to this like even
back in the [ __ ] [ __ ] 50s and 60s
and [ __ ] but
this still looks and they didn't have
cgi
or anything like that really i mean i
think they did it with some green
screening and that's but you can't
really tell like the way they shot it
you can't tell where the split screen is
you can't tell
so they actually did have i think they
had a little bit of maybe computer
technology to do that
but it looks great i mean it still looks
really good
yeah it's it it's believable it's very
confusing yeah it totally is
and i think the one of the best things
about it too is that jeremy irons
performance in this is such that you
never
he never even has to talk you can tell
which twin that is
just by and his hair is not different
his clothes aren't noticeably different
it just has to do with i don't it's just
a deli
it's his body language it's it's
everything it's like the way he holds
his facial expressions and it's just
like really it's nothing you can really
put your finger on
but the second you see one of them on
screen you know which one is which yeah
it's nothing about this movie
and and a lot of cronenberg movies
especially the older ones
the acting is good but it's not is
usually as good as this
the acting in this is very good yeah
there's a certain tone in certain
cronenberg movies where
there's kind of like you said kind of
like a sterility to it
yeah you know and it's like he's chosen
actors that kind of deliver [ __ ] that
way still and sterile
this one isn't really like that not at
all this one actually is has really good
acting in it
it is a very different cronenberg movie
i feel like this was kind of at this
point
and i'm not saying like the fly was very
different um
is is different but i do feel like this
is almost
a little bit thematically similar
because the fly was also kind of
a twisted love story yeah fly which this
is too kind of
the fly always kind of always kind of
made the impression on me as
would be like what if steven spielberg
made a made a body horror movie
because the fly had a very mainstream
sci-fi even though it wasn't totally
over the top even though it was over top
weird [ __ ] [ __ ]
but it still is felt very mainstream
like yeah like you were watching a lucas
or uh
or or a spielberg movie but what it was
cronenberg yeah i like that movie and i
mean well everybody loves that movie
i like species species was like a
mainstream movie that had
uh kind of dark tones to it you know
what i mean
i would i put the fly on the same level
say like species
yeah the movie species i think the fly
is way better than species but yeah
i like species too but i don't like the
species i mean the fly i think is easily
one of the best
horror movies of the 80s um and most
people i think would agree with that
assessment it's just it's a great movie
it's got like a great emotional core to
it
um so that's why why i think it's very
confusing that when people say about
cronenberg being always so clinical and
stuff but
he's actually very good at directing
actors when he has really good actors
because i think
you know prior to maybe when he made the
dead zone um
you know which had christopher walken in
it i feel like he you know because he
was making lower budget movies
yeah when he was making lower budget
movies he maybe didn't have access to
like kind of your big a-list actors and
everything so once he got you know
you know once christopher walken was in
the dead zone and that got so much
you know attention so i feel like he had
access to like
more like in better actors and he seems
to be very good at
bringing the best out of them yeah you
know what i'm saying
so i mean cronenberg was like uh
this is [ __ ] john carpenter's
favorite director he was
they were buddies yeah and man
when carpenter was when he was when he
was on when he was on point
carpenter was really good but i'd have
to say
i think overall to just the total body
of work i'd have to give it to
cronenberg
i can't really think of a cronenberg
movie that i haven't seen
that i didn't uh enjoy to some extent
i don't know if enjoyable think a lot of
the later i think a lot of the later
carpenter films didn't have carpenter
and too involved in them yeah they
didn't really seem to have his
thumbprints on them they didn't seem
like whereas when you see a cronenberg
movie even if it's
a desk even if it's not a horror movie
because he did go more in like a crime
thriller direction later like when he
made eastern promises and history of
violence and stuff like that with fiega
mortensen
and um you know they're still fantastic
movies they're just not the same genre
anymore
but they're still you can still tell
that that's a cronenberg movie
and i think that's kind of like um you
know just a testament to his
vision and his genius and everything
like that is even when he makes
something in a genre that he's not
really
associated with you can still tell that
that's him directing it
yeah i guess you could say he he was
kind of like the canadian kubrick isn't
he
yeah it's not exactly the same but he
does have a similar
it is a very similar aesthetic i guess
well i'm just saying in greatness
well that's he's kind of like kind of
like canada's
stanley kubrick yeah and i mean kubrick
and cronenberg are
two of my favorite directors i mean my
very favorite director is probably david
lynch but i mean
you know they're kubrick and cronenberg
are top five easily
kubrick was a man though dude is a
[ __ ] genius well yeah
yeah but um yeah so all right so so you
have these two
twins and like i said it almost seems
like they're
not a complete person on their own
because
elliott uh who is the more
outgoing of the two like he's kind of
the public face of their
clinic like he's the one that goes out
and gives the speeches and gets the
grants and stuff like that
but he's also very shallow and vain
and a little bit sociopathic um kind of
in the sense that he doesn't really
care about anyone uh but himself and his
brother
whereas beverly is more um and i think
the reason they gave him a quote-unquote
girl's name because
you know later on somebody makes a
comment about him having a girl's name
even though
technically back then that was a you
know a name that could have been a boy's
name or a girl's name
but um you know he's kind of more uh
you know internal he's more he's the one
that does the studying he's the one that
does the research
he's more shy he's more introverted um
so so it's almost like they're two
halves of a whole
but they you know don't have
you know they don't have like any
overlap like in their personality traits
you know what i'm saying so they they
can't like survive without the other at
least that's how they perceive
themselves
like they perceive themselves as one
being
um with just these two halves they go
out because they they switch
places all the time because you know
because they learn a lot of twins are
like that though
yeah it's true it's true they don't
really differentiate much between one
between one and the other i mean they
got the same dna it must be really weird
i always thought
like i said i i have a couple sets of
twins in my family
and i you know they always seem like
normal to me but
and they didn't do any like weird spooky
twin [ __ ] that i knew of
but um and i could always tell them
apart too but but i have but i always
thought of that like when i was growing
up because i used to hang out with a
couple of my cousins that were twins and
i always used to wonder what that would
be like i'm like that i heard
twin girls were usually more bonded than
the twin boys though
uh yeah that makes sense i mean just
because
you know in general like they wanted to
live together
well in general women are more like
empathetic or more
like you know connected with families
and stuff like that not always
obviously because that's kind of a
generalization but in
be a weird we did that show on those
twins remember yeah that's what i
thought half of them crazy twins were
twin twin sisters
yeah they did crazy [ __ ] which reminds
me if you want to see another crazy twin
movie
see sisters directed by brian de palma
from the 1970s we should probably
i don't know if you've ever seen that
margo kitters in it she plays the twins
uh that's kind of more a good twin evil
tool which i guess this one is too
but it this one is a lot more subtle
than that
yeah because what ends up happening with
this one is that so these two
have they're weird but they're not like
off-puttingly weird
um and i feel like they've been
professionally successful you know
they're geniuses they've invented this
you know gynecological tool that's now
the industry standard the mantle
retractor
and um you know have had all these
accolades for it so shit's working out
for them pretty good it's like you know
they have a team thing going on
uh you know they can switch out when
they need to if one of them doesn't feel
like doing this thing they can
send somebody out to have dinner with
whoever and it's fine you know what i
mean
so you know or you know do each other's
patients or
whatnot so they seem to have this all
sorted out and then
comes the destabilizing influence
of claire neveaux now she is this
actress
that comes to town and she comes to
their uh she's working on a mini series
or something
and she comes to their fertility clinic
because you know she's
getting a little bit older and she feels
like as they say in the movie that her
life is empty without a child
and she has not been able to get
pregnant even though as she mentions to
beverly earlier in the film that she has
been quote unquote very promiscuous
and has never used birth control but
she's never been able to get pregnant
and she's wondering why that
is so they do find out later that she
has a very rare
a fabulously rare mutation a trifurcated
cervix which i think is actually a real
thing i don't know if anybody can have
try for i've heard of like bifurcated
ones but basically the cervix has three
openings when it's
normally supposed to have one so uh
basically you know dr mantle says i
don't think you can ever get pregnant
this is a very it's a very unusual
mutation
but because she's like oh maybe i can
have three babies like i can have
triplets like one in each compartment
and he's like yeah that's not how it
works um so she gets really upset about
it and she's very vulnerable now
she ends up what because what's been
going on is that elliott
uh the [ __ ] brother he what he will
do
is he will seduce you know any woman
maybe some
some of their patients too which is
super unethical but whatever
and so he'll seduce one of the patients
then bang him for a while and then he'll
get sick of them
and then he'll pass them on to sweet
sensitive beverly
because he says to beverly early in the
film you would still be a virgin if it
wasn't for me
um and they they tend to like go after
women that are from out of town
they imply because you know they don't
know that there's two of them
so they can switch them back and forth
without the woman being the wiser
and indeed that is what happens with
claire nouveau elliott bangs her for a
little while then he says he gets sick
of her so
you know then beverly starts you know
then he passes her off
to beverly now what ends up happening
though
is that bev actually ends up falling in
love with her
and subsequently she finds out that she
has been the filling
in the mantle brothers oreo and she is
not
happy about it she is like pretty
[ __ ] grossed out because
she was starting to get i don't think
she was suspicious that they were twins
but she thought that
bev because she thought he was the only
one that she was seeing she thought that
he was schizophrenic
because you know sometimes she'd have a
date with him and he'd be really nice
and then sometimes he'd be a real dick
and then so she thought there was
something to batter with him but then
later on she finds out through like a
mutual friend or something that they're
actually twins and she twigs pretty
quick to what is going on they've been
switching her out and she is completely
disgusted by the whole situation
as you naturally would be so she has a
big thing and they
you know they have a big fight and they
break up however
um her and bev like elliot really
doesn't seem to care cause like i said
he's kind of a sociopath and he was just
using her anyway and he
he mistakenly i guess um
tells bev it's like oh she was just like
hitting us up for drugs because she does
actually like you know they do actually
start prescribing drugs for her
and um so he's just like whatever she's
an actress she's a flake they're all
like that you know she's messed up they
all messed up
but bev is really upset about it so they
do
try to kind of come to some uneasy peace
about it
but as it goes on you know bev
becoming who is very emotionally
vulnerable
him getting more and more involved with
this woman
is destabilizing his relationship with
his brother
now also his brother is becoming kind of
jealous of their relationship because
and he's also kind of upset
that claire didn't want him because
of his ego like you know because like i
see he's very vain
so that kind of bothers him as well so
there's like this big
um you know conflict between all three
of them
and he's kind of trying to pull bev
out of the thing like trying to get him
involved with his girlfriend and they're
trying to do a threesome with the two
twin brothers and
it's it's very messed up um but
as it goes on bev starts descending
into drug addiction and madness
um to a point where because him and
claire were starting to do all these
drugs and then he just you know she went
off to do
a movie somewhere else and he couldn't
handle it like he couldn't handle her
being gone
so he started taking all these drugs to
a point where you know
it was affecting his work and then he
started getting really crazy and
thinking
that all of the women that were coming
to see him
were mutated somehow because he had
become so obsessed with claire
that because that was one of the things
that drew their attention to her in the
first place was her
you know mutation of her cervix so then
he starts
mistakenly thinking that every woman
that comes to them has some kind of
weird
mutation like there's this one really
funny
horrific scene where he's like he has
the retractor thing and he's like
sticking it up in this woman's yeah his
mouth
yeah and and she's like you know that
really hurts and he's like what if it's
it doesn't hurt it's not supposed to
hurt and all this other stuff and like
he's arguing with her about whether it
hurts or not
a solid goal doesn't hurt yeah and it's
well and then later you find out that
that's not even supposed to go there
that's not for that
particular thing it's not like the
speculum that is supposed to go up there
that you know that's shaped like that
the right thing to go up there but then
he's like implying
that she that maybe her insides are
mutated because she
slept with the dog yeah and like all
this other kind of stuff
so he's starting to like lose his mind
he goes to this like
industrial artist at this gallery in
town and he has all these drawings
for all of these gynecological tools for
working
on mutants yeah it's all this custom
shape
that's and stuff
yeah it's just like these crazy i mean
obviously you look they look like
torture implements
i mean they're beautiful looking but
when you look at them you're like yeah i
don't want that anywhere
near my vagina thank you but it's like
so he has them made
um because he is starting to like all
the drugs
and his you know kind of emotional
breakdown of her being gone and like him
and his brother like being at odds
is making him crazy and making him think
that everybody
is mutated like i mean he he's arguing
with his brother it's like about the
putting the retractor in that woman's
vagina and her like saying that it hurt
it's like it's not the tool it's it's
all of them there's something wrong with
all of their bodies they're
wrong inside like everybody's mutated so
he's starting to get like these
delusions
so for a while elliot does he's not a
complete sociopath he does
love his brother i don't know if it's so
much love as he's
dependent on his brother because he even
says to his
sort of on off girlfriend that he
doesn't
that he wouldn't have a career without
beverly because beverly was the one that
did all the research
i mean elliot was just the one that you
know was the face of it because he was
like a social butterfly he was the one
that did the speeches and stuff so he
was kind of like the the outward facing
thing but beverly was the one that was
doing all the hard work behind the
scenes
and so he's basically well i wouldn't
have her career without him so i need
him
so he tries at first to
you know detox bev off the drugs
so he locks him in the clinic and he
puts somebody you know makes him not
take drugs and everything like that but
then it's not really working out
so then he gets the idea that well
okay maybe to do this we need to
synchronize
so we both need to be drug addicts and
then
i can you know be down there at the same
place as him and then we can both come
out
together this is where i think it
started to tie in
this is a fantastically bad idea yeah
with the brothers that were that this
was based off of
in real life how [ __ ] weird [ __ ] went
with those dudes because after a while
and i i thought that was genius the way
they did this in the movie because after
like i said at the beginning you could
easily tell which brother was which
but then like as it goes on and they
both descend and they
start feeding off each other's drug
addiction and feeding off each other's
madness you can't tell them apart
that well anymore like you still can but
they start dressing the same they start
acting the same so it's almost kind of
like they're trying to merge
into one another which like i said
that's kind of the theme of the whole
movie is that they're trying to like get
back
into the womb where they were still
one cell or whatever so
you know what i mean because they can't
i mean there's really one reverse birth
yeah so it's like i said that's why
they're so obsessed with like the
insides of women's bodies
and so there's like there's this really
great scene pretty much the only like
quote unquote
you know old-school david cronenberg
body horror type of scene
where beverly has a dream where him and
claire
are in bed and then you look over and uh
and
elliot is over there too like looking at
them and then they pull back
and bev and elliot are attached like at
the
abdomen like with this weird fleshy
they're like siamese twins yeah like
siamese twins because and that's another
thing that repeats is
you know telling the story of chang and
eng and how they died and uh stuff like
that that's kind of like a big
touchstone in the movie as well
and then you know then he's talking
about we have to separate them and then
claire goes into like bites through like
trying to
chew through the [ __ ] flesh now
apparently they shot another scene
for this where i guess there was like um
a parasitic twin was gonna come out of
beverly's stomach
but i guess they didn't either it didn't
test well or cronenberg thought that it
was too much
which is strange because usually he's
like gorset but in
i think in this movie i think the
restraint
was the right thing to do i think it
could have easily gone
really wrong if they tried to do too
much gore
or too much over the top
kind of stuff you know what i'm saying
because i like the way it just
focused mostly on the psychology of the
characters and how the character
psychology breaks down
rather than i mean i did like the body
horror touches but i think it was good
that he kept it kind of to a minimum
yeah it just i think it's a matter of
opinion i think i would like it to go on
a little bit [ __ ] weirder
actually yeah just that's just me you
know yeah i can see that
um the movie's very dialogue
driven and character-driven for me it
doesn't really pay off as a horror movie
i would call it more a psychological
horror movie or a character study
with horror elements and it got really
weird at the
at the end of it and built up as i think
i would have liked it a little better i
mean this is a good movie i mean
i love this we're going to say that you
know
that cronenberg is like it is is the
kubrick of canada
this would be his eyes wide shut this
you know talk about this oh i don't know
about this
i think so where it's not really over
time it's just it's just a good movie
yeah cause i like eyes wide shut yeah i
didn't really like it on the first
viewing
but on multiple viewings eyes wide shut
got better although i have to say i like
this better than i swatch it
yeah dead ringers i'd say they're about
on par i mean like i said dead ringers
is one of my favorite cronenberg movies
and it's been one of my favorite movies
from the 80s like for a really long time
there's just something about it that i
really like
and honestly it's not it's not just the
horror elements it's not just the
psychology elements
i like a lot of the dialogue i like the
interplay
between the two twins i like um you know
the dynamic of this like [ __ ] up
relationship between the two of them and
between this woman
like some of the lines in it are so
[ __ ] great it's like you know
when [ __ ] elliot's up there giving
the speech and like bev comes in and
he's all drunk and
he's like i want to say something i want
to say something he's like you know this
he's like talking about how they how
they separate the workload and he's like
why slave over the hot snatches
and he writes the speeches like you know
what i mean and it's just like this
great [ __ ] lines like that
um so i just really like and i love the
whole scene with
uh the first time that claire realizes
that they're twins like she sees them in
the
diner together and realizes that she's
been [ __ ] both of them without
knowing it
and um and just like that whole
interaction because elliot's kind of
trying to pretend that he's never met
her before and
she's like not having it and then you
know she's like oh there really is no
telling you a part is there and he's
you know elliot's like oh i'm actually a
couple of millimeters taller
and then she's like no i'm pretty sure i
have another way i can tell you apart
it's like he's the sweet one and you're
the [ __ ]
yeah so it's just like there's just
really great
dynamic between the three of them even
though it's just two actors it's
it's a good movie yeah yeah um it
wouldn't be my first pick for a
cronenberg movie i would say
see the brood or video drum yeah i mean
he's got so many good ones
right he's got a lot of cards if you
like the movie if you like
those movies and you haven't seen this
one you need to see it because i feel
like this is more it this one took a
while
because like i said the fly was a huge
success
this one was like i guess kind of a six
it's got like you know pretty good
reviews at the time i feel like the
reputation of this one has gotten better
over the years um it got a criterion
collection
uh you know released a few years back
and it's turned up on a lot of list you
know top 10 canadian movies um
you know it comes up on a lot of horror
lists you know an underrated horror
and stuff even though like i said it's
it's a horror movie in a sense
but i think it's more toward the
psychological horror
and that's why i'm gonna say that this
is uh this is cronenberg's version of
eyes wide [ __ ]
yeah which yeah i can see you know what
i'm saying
yeah it's it
it stands in in cronenberg's catalog
it's about the same level of where eyes
wide shut stands in
kubrick's catalog something that kind of
aged better with time it takes multiple
viewings
yeah it's uh it got pretty good reviews
but it's
not as good as some of the other ones
it's something that kind of had to age
i think and this one has really aged
very well
i think and the thing about this one too
even though it's sort of loosely based
on a true story where
you know spoiler alert they both died
which they do in the movie as well
but there's something really sad about
this movie as well it's very tragic
because one of my favorite things i just
love you know when he
when he has these tools made and
obviously makes a big show of like you
know their tools for
operating on mutant women but then later
on in the movie when claire finds them
because he's gone and stolen them from
the artist
and she's like what are these tools what
are they for and he says he doesn't say
they're for
operating on women he says they're for
separating siamese twins
and when he takes them back to his house
and they both go into this like descent
into madness
and like they're [ __ ] you know they
have like crap and [ __ ] all over their
apartment
and they haven't been out anywhere and
they're all sick and they're like eating
cake and they look all [ __ ] up and
boxer shorts and whatnot and um
so he decides he's going to use the
tools and elliot says it's okay
to separate the siamese twins so he's
basically saying yes kill me
what he's saying is he wants bev to
separate himself from elliot so that bev
can go have a life
with claire you know what i mean so
that's that was why elliott
did that however that's not how it works
out because bev
kills elliot he gets all upset about it
yeah spoiler and then well no i just
said i'm gonna spoil it they both die at
the end
he kills elliot and then like he goes
outside
like he puts on his clothes he packs up
he goes outside and he goes to a phone
booth and calls claire and she says you
know hello who is this or whatever
then he hangs up and then he goes back
into the apartment
and dies with his brother and the and
the last shot looks like the pieta which
i think is very funny
what's that at least you like that
virgin mary jesus type of thing with
like you know
uh you know the mary jesus uh thing that
they always put in paintings and whatnot
the weights paused
but that's another call back to the
chang and thing too because
he had a little he said a little rhyme
earlier about what had happened to chang
and eng that
one of one of them had died in his sleep
and then when the other one woke up and
saw
that the brother was dead he died a
fright and so
it it looks like that's kind of what
they were setting up because it was like
the dead one is up against the wall and
then he's like laying across with his
eyes wide open and he's dead
um so like i said it's a tragic ending
because it's almost like elliott
you know obviously you knew it wasn't
going to work out because you can't just
kill a dude and wander off and
everything be hunky-dory but
symbolically that's what elliott wanted
he's like you know i want you to
separate yourself from me and then go
have a life
by yourself but bev was not able to
because he couldn't live without his
brother because they weren't they
weren't an entire person
you know what i mean they couldn't be an
entire person like on their own they
were two halves
so he couldn't live without his other
half so he just went back there and died
with his brother
and so it's like i said it's a very sad
ending and
honestly jeremy irons was [ __ ]
amazing in this probably should have won
an oscar he did actually win an oscar
two years later for a reversal of
fortune
and uh when he was up there accepting it
he he thanked david kernerberg and it
was i guess it was because of this movie
that he got to do it and
maybe that's what led to him doing
reversal of fortune i haven't seen
reversal of fortune in a really long
time i remember that being good too but
i think i liked this one a lot better
like i said there's just something about
this it's not super over the top it's
not super gory
um you know there's just like a couple
touches of the body horror type stuff
you can still tell it's a cronenberg
movie obviously because of the art
direction and because of the
subject matter and uh this weird
psychosexual undertone to it
um but it's kind of a more
i don't want to use the word adult or
it's kind of like a more mature
movie maybe it's just kind of like his
version of like a weird psychosexual
drama
you know what i'm saying or like a
character study but as i said it's
surprisingly funny as well like it has a
lot of like really dark humor which i
really like
but yeah so if you like cronenberg and
you haven't seen it because i know a lot
of people haven't like weirdly
i've seen a lot of uh reviews of horror
fans that have seen a lot of other
cronenberg but haven't seen this one
um then i would definitely recommend you
check it out because it's
it's just really really good like the
acting is really good and it's just like
this really weird creepy
experience um so that'll do it for
our movie retrospective uh remember like
share subscribe all that jazz
and we'll see you next time bye